una sonrisa serena ante un despegue
hacia lo desconocido yuri gagarín fue
elegido entre un grupo de élite de
pilotos de guerra soviéticos en parte
por sus nervios de acero el 12 de abril
de 1961 el joven de 27 años se deslizaba
dentro de una pequeña cápsula diseñada
para transportar una cabeza nuclear
pocos garantizaban que sobreviviría los
más optimistas le daban un 50% de
posibilidades cuando lo propulsaron
hacia el cielo mantuvo un tono confiado
yo puedo ver la tierra las distintas
capas del paisaje los bosques y las
nubes
la cápsula viajo a 28 mil kilómetros por
hora en una hora y 48 minutos se
completó la órbita la tierra
una innegable victoria para la unión
soviética que se convirtió en el primer
país en mandar un hombre al espacio
fue una ampliación para eeuu en medio de
la guerra fría la unión soviética se
presentaba como el líder científico
mundial que le tocó ser ramo para en ese
momento no sabíamos en que nos metíamos
mandamos a gente al espacio sin saber lo
que pasaría por eso hay un verdadero
culto a la personalidad de gagarín en
rusia están muy orgullosos de ese
periodo la siguiente misión de gagarín
fue diplomática un tour mundial para
celebrar su proeza
ver mi patria desde el espacio fue uno
de los momentos más increíbles de mi
vida
era el embajador perfecto para la unión
soviética lee la encarnación a gritos él
mismo era la personificación de la
bandera soviética hijo de granjeros laúd
y herrero el martillo y todo lo que hizo
a partir de ahí todo lo que aprendió
como herrero el convertirse en piloto de
guerra fue gracias a la unión soviética
así que sabían que sería un símbolo
perfecto de sólimo mainichi después de
lidiar con la depresión finalmente
volvió a entrenar pero murió en 1968 en
un ejercicio con sólo 34 años de edad